[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Liquid refreshment
can leave its mark on the table.
Coasters come between
the glass and that.
But two centuries ago, coasters
were mainly placed on the rim
of the glass to keep out flies.
Made of felt, they
unfortunately spread germs.
So the cardboard coaster
was invented to improve
hygiene on the pub scene.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Beverage coasters
protect the table,
and are also a marketing tool.
Raise the glass and you'll
see advertising catchphrases
and promotional graphics.
In fact, some bar hoppers
consider coasters pub art
and accumulate vast collections.
Production at this
facility in Germany
starts with spruce wood.
In this case, it's from
the Black Forrest nearby.
They spray the wood with
water to moisten the bark.
Then it's into a tumbler
that tosses the wood logs.
As they knock against each
other, the bark peels off.
The debarked wood exits
onto a conveyor with slots
to correctly orient it for
entry into a massive grinder.
Inside, chains press the wood
logs against a grinding stone,
shredding them into chips.
Water flows over the grinding
stone to cool it and carry away
the chips, which are then
mixed into a mesh that has
a porridge-like consistency.
It's pure would pop.
They now add leftover
product from previous beer
coaster production to the pulp.
This will be used to
make the middle layer
of the beer coasters.
Finally, they mix residual
paper from the manufacturer
of magazines and
envelopes with water.
This creates a
lighter colored pulp.
It will be used for
the printable surfaces
of the beer coaster.
They spray the pulp onto a
mesh that drains water from it.
The fibrous wood core
goes between the layers
of the lighter pulp.
Spickets apply a mix of wheat,
starch, and water that acts
as a glue between the layers.
Off the mesh conveyers
now, the pulp board
travels between cylinders
that squeeze out the moisture.
More heated cylinders dry it.
Knives now cut the board
into large rectangles,
sized for the coaster printing
and cutting machinery.
This specialty cardboard
is known as woodpulp board.
It's lightweight yet
highly absorbent.
Next, it's over to the
printing department
to put the beer coaster
artwork on the wood pulp board.
They use offset printing,
a process that involves
more revolving cylinders.
Color cylinders pick
up ink and transfer
it to the printing cylinders.
From there, the image goes to
a rubber wrapped cylinder that
then prints it onto the sheets.
A print specialist scrutinizes
the print job close
up with a magnifying glass.
He checks the color and
clarity of the images
and confirms that
they're correctly
positioned on the sheet.
The borders of the images must
line up with the grit of blades
on the dye cutting machinery.
If the alignment is
even slightly off,
every coaster on the
sheet would be ruined,
as the dye cutter
punches out the coasters,
dozens of them in one swoop.
The coasters end up
over little chutes,
and pushers give them a nudge.
They fall down the chutes and
land neatly on a pallet below.
The coasters stack up.
And when there are a
hundred or so in each pile,
they're ready for packaging.
Machinery shrink
wraps the stacks.
And they're ready for
the thirsty masses.
This factory can produce
and package 10 million
offset printed beer
coasters every day,
so there should be no
shortage at cocktail hour.
They also print coasters using
a centuries-old technology
known as letterpress.
Blank coasters drop
down into the machine.
A rolling wheel presses each
coaster against an ink plate.
It's a system that
both prints the image
and imbosses it
on the cardboard.
It's a difference you
can both see and feel.
Letterpress production is lower
volume than offset, generating
100,000 coasters per day.
For coasters, the design
possibilities are endless.
Just raise the glass and enjoy.